[Music]
okay thank you everybody for being here
how did you like the sessions before is
it good yeah no okay we're going to try
to make this one good so we're going to
talk about vs code and kubernetes but
before i do that let me introduce myself
I'm David Garrow I'm a developer
advocate on the cloud platform I'm based
out of Paris and I'm I love everything
else related to developer experience and
I love cats and there's no connection
between you two you can find me on
Twitter and github okay so what is it
like to be a developer in humanities
world
are there any developers here in the
room yeah doing deploying to kubernetes
yeah how do you like it okay yeah who
doesn't like it
okay most of the people like it because
my opinion is that it's a mess like the
house is on fire and everybody says yeah
it's fine like this
billions of tools billions of layers
lots of complexity but you don't have to
trust me we ask our users what they
think about how hard it is to develop
applications for Q&S and they found it
frustrating they said that there's too
much configuration
they said that debugging is a pain when
you used to debugging inside your ID
debugging for something that's deployed
on Q virus cluster is very complicated
they said that applications have too
many moving parts and basically they
want to spend more time on their code
who wants to spend more time on their
code I do so today for next we
introduced cloud code code code is a set
of extensions for IntelliJ and vs code
and they will help you as a developer to
get more predictive and focused on your
code and just work on your code edit
your applications deployed and
continuously to a cluster who wants to
see that in action yeah okay so let's do
the demo whoops let's do the demo
so I'm gonna start by starting Claude
code vs code so in vs car oof okay
so you don't see it can you see it now
okay on the bar on the left there's a
new icon which is the card cut extension
if I click on it I can see all the
clusters that I have access to and right
now what I have is dr. desktop which
gives me a Cuban as poster on my local
machine and I can browse my what's deep
blowing on my cluster and I can see that
I have not no deployments I've got maybe
a few parts there's one pod that's
running one container and you can see
here in action already that crud code
makes you very productive you don't have
to use the cni to browse what you do in
one cluster and you can connect to a
container and stream the logs hey ello
Club next we see the logs that are from
that container we can also maybe go
inside one of the container and get a
terminal okay yeah from it all I'm
inside a container it's running on a
cluster whether it's local or remote I
don't care it's quite easy you can do
the same thing with the cube City or CLI
but from your IDE it's more comfortable
right okay right I've got one in one
cluster I'm and I'm going to want to
deploy it on the cloud and because it's
Google cloud I'm going to deploy it on
gke but in fact cloud code makes it
possible to create from my IDE a cluster
on any cloud provider I can create a
cluster on AWS on asier
I can create of course a GK cluster so
for my demo I'm gonna click on create GK
cluster and inside my ID I'm gonna have
a wizard very simplified version of the
cluster creation wizard that helps me
create a cluster for my development so
I'm going to use the default project ID
I'm gonna choose one of the zones I'm
gonna put I don't know this one maybe
and I'm gonna give it
I'm gonna give a name to my cluster and
that's it I'm gonna create the cluster
it's going to take a few minutes in the
background is going to create the
cluster and when it's done is going to
appear in the bottom-left section here
where I can see all my clusters on the
cloud okay so I've got a cluster that's
going to be created I want to work on
some code but I don't really know how to
get started and we'll little new to
cubed s so I'm going to use one of the
features from cloud code which is very
useful which is the new application
creation with cloud code we are shipping
code samples that you can use to learn
kubernetes platform to learn to code
applications with your favorite language
for kubernetes so you have the choice
between Python go node.js java.net and
you have simple or more complicated
samples it's a good way to get started
and I'm going to choose one I'm going to
choose the the go hello world yeah so
it's going to clone that project is
going to open a new window with that
project and it's a fully configured
project very easy but that helps me to
get started
it's a typical go application so I can
see the sources here there's a CMD
package there's a mango it's basically
going to run a web server on port 8080
and it's going to say hello world very
simple but there's also docker file ok
to containerize that application it's
already created for me there's all
what's needed to compile the application
but also what's neat debug it and
there's also a few kubernetes manifest
that can learn from i can learn from -
to learn about kubernetes what's
interesting here is that i can hover on
any keyword and I have the full
documentation from the Kuban test
manifest so I can really start to
understand what each configuration means
and it's really very useful and also
have like validation for example here
it's waiting for an integer so I cannot
type this time this type of value here
got service and for example for the type
I can have like completion ups
I have completion that no yeah come on I
don't know what's going on okay demo
effect usually have completion so it
really helps me to to get started right
so now I want to deploy that application
on docker desktop and you'd expect to
run some kind of command chain like Doc
opa-locka poop CTL apply but you don't
really want to do that you're inside
your IDE you want to focus on your code
so you're going to use cloud code to
deploy your application you're going to
choose deploy and deploy will do
everything I said for you automatically
I'm gonna deploy it with the default
profile I'm going to deploy it on doc
Edisto yeah so it's going to build the
image is gonna tag the image it's gonna
put the image name in the llamo and it's
going to send it to cuban address and
when it's done it's going to give me the
URL that i can connect to and see that
it's deployed you see so it's really
easy i can just focus on my code I can
learn Cuban address and I say deploy
code code and boom it's deployed okay do
you find it nice is it good is it good
already
yeah so it's really he here to you to
help you get started okay because a lot
of people don't know the platform
there's so many layers so many comments
that you have to learn it's easier if
the idea does it for you okay but what
did I want to say okay so all of this is
possible because cloud code is using a
product underneath that's called
scaffold and scaffold as a configuration
file that you can see here you don't
have to learn that configuration file
because code code will do it for you
most of the time but basically what it
says is all the images I want to build
all the other sides I want to deploy
which tool is going to be used to deploy
whether it's you CTL or ham you can have
profiles etc etc you can say how the
images are going to be tagged and once
this configuration is there you don't
have to think about it and it's there
already for all the samples so you can
just type thread around deploy and it's
going to be deployed
okay I've got a more complicated project
that I want to work on which is a guest
book so this one is not finished it's
not a sample it's it's just work in
progress so work in progress so what can
I say about this project so it's not yes
now and I've got a backhand with an
entry point I've got a docx file that
I've created also I've got a front-end
entry point and the dacha file and I
started already to type some of the
various manifest somebody gave it give
them to to me and there is one
deployment to deploy MongoDB and there
is a secret that gives a username and
password to database and that my
backends should use to connect to the
backend by the way you can see that here
third code is also here to help you by
giving you tools to decode base64
username and password for example it's
very convenient okay but I need more
more Gamal files right because given
this is about yeah mol files right so
I'm gonna do one way I will find for my
back-end back in okay the good ol white
page what should i type can you help me
it's really complicated so third code is
here to help
so it's clot code oh my completion is
just okay glad code is going to help me
type typical deployment I'm gonna say
deployment okay deployment it's gonna be
the back end I need to choose an image
name I'm gonna just put it back in okay
and that I don't know
so of course you still have to
understand what you're typing but card
code is here to help
same for the service you don't have to
type or copy/paste you just use that and
start from here
okay and I know that the node
application is running on port 9000 okay
should be good this was very quick right
I'm going to do the same thing for the
service for the front-end sorry front
end so I'm gonna have a deployment I'm
gonna change the image name I don't know
what I'm going to put there but front
end okay and I'm gonna add a service so
this time my service needs to be exposed
to the outside so it's gonna be a load
balancer so I'm gonna type service give
it a name
oops and I'm gonna choose a load
balancer yeah a lot better completion
okay so I've got all the types that I
can use and I know this is load balancer
and a wall and I can shake the
documentation and yes that's exactly
what I want okay so this was this was
quite quick no more copy pasting it's
not perfect we want to improve that in
the future but already it helps you get
started it's it helps you when you have
a blank page it's not really a great
experience and this time it's much
better so I'm gonna deploy that to my
cluster right so code code deploy oh
okay there's a problem because okay I've
got like dhaka files and manifest but
it's not enough for cloud code to
understand what I want to deploy
I mean witchdoctor file is building
which image and which imagined you is
used in which cuba is manifest so that
was the point of the scaffold yeah Mon I
showed you and I don't want to type that
so I'm gonna I'm gonna let Clark god
help me to type that do you want to
create a new profile yes so basically
all I have to do is I've got the image
names that squad code found in my young
files and here there's the daka files
and i just need to make pairs so that's
quite easy right okay the back end of
files for the back end front ends front
front end and [ __ ] [ __ ] is just an
image that's going to be pulled
from the dock aha so I'm gonna save that
and proceed to deploy it there's a lot
of options that I could tweak with the
UI but I just wanted to be deployed as
quick as possible
so it's gotta be deployed oh there's a
problem there's a problem
it looks like my code is relying on some
environment viable so I told you that
it's going to connect to MongoDB it
needs a username and a password to
connect to MongoDB so I'm going to use
the values that are in the secret and
I'm going to use them in the backend
yeah more configuration but before I do
that let me introduce you to a new mode
of deployment that you have incurred
code
it's called continuous continuous
deployment when I do continuously deploy
what is gonna do is going to deploy an
application but each time I change
something like config file or the
sources is going to rebuild what needs
to be rebuilt it's gonna really probably
what needs to be redeployed I just need
to focus on my code that's it okay no
more deploying it's going to be done
automatically so I can just fix my issue
okay MongoDB username there's it needs
environment variables so I'm gonna
configure it here I'm gonna add a rival
available there it needs a name I'm
gonna use the value from the secret so
it's going to be a secret and cloud code
we even complete the name of the secrets
that I have in my project so I don't
have to type them and I have to copy
paste ok mando go DB and it's gonna be
the user name I can just save and boom
third code we try to really plug my
application in the background it's very
quick and now it's complaining about the
password okay let's do the password but
you get the point you can really focus
on fixing your your code and you can let
cloud called do the rest
completion is going to be the password
but by the way if I right click here on
[ __ ] secret it will show me the secret
in the other yellow file it will even
show me the version that's already
deployed I'm sorry already po in
production let me do that again
sorry here this is a version that G
that's deployed on the cluster so that's
really super useful I can start to
connect the pieces together and start to
understand the links between all those
manifests and all those objects ok so
I'm gonna save that and I'm gonna let Q
cloud code deploy it automatically for
me and when it's done it's going to give
me an end point cross finger yeah
gas book that was quite easy I didn't
copy paste anything I did not run any
chain of commands it's deployed on my
cluster that's nice right so I can use
it can use my app hello next and you can
see it's working but there's there's a
bug here there's a bug so when there's a
bug we need to point it to debug ok so
we're going to try to debug that
application but I was told that
debugging applications on kuvira's was
very complicated because it's not
running locally on my machine it's
running on a cluster somewhere on a body
it's quite complicated but it's cloud
code it doesn't have to be complicated
I'm going to switch to the debug tab I'm
going to debug the backend and it's
going to connect to my application it's
running on a pod on a container but it
doesn't matter it can connect to it it
can debug it from visual vs code as any
other application I'm gonna put a
breakpoint somewhere that I know okay
this one I'm gonna just refresh where is
it
I'm gonna just refresh and boom ok I'm
debugging it I've got a full day where I
can debug I can I've got a console I can
print values anything I can jump to the
other the next breakpoint and I can see
that it's sending a message with a name
oh there's a typo here must mean by
burger okay
I'm gonna fix that I'm gonna save it and
boom cut code is already redeploying
everything in production and it's
already blown and it's eating the
breakpoint again yeah it worked okay
so it's actually easy to debug an
application with code code you don't
have to know where it's running it's
very easy to do it with just one click
okay I've got three minutes so I told
you I would deploy it on kubera ass
where is my cluster where is my cluster
okay
so loading so yeah there's a cluster
here so I'm going to deploy it to that
cluster so how do I do that I just asked
code code to deploy if I'm gonna do
deploy but this time oops sorry
I'm gonna stop that I'm gonna deploy yes
no sorry
too quick I'm going to deploy but this
time I'm gonna add profile
I'm not going to deploy in my
development environment locally I'm
going to deploy to a new cluster which
is my demo cluster but for that I need a
new profile like development production
staging whatever you can add as many
profiles as you want so I'm gonna add a
file I'm gonna call it production and I
could tweak the word images our build
proper action or the way that images are
deployed for production but let's keep
it this way and do the same thing but
with a different cluster so I'm going to
proceed with deployment and do a
prediction here third card is asking me
in which cluster I want to deploy when I
deploy to production because it's the
first time I blog is that profile
somewhere switch to demo cluster and
because then my image is needs to be
pushed to registry because I'm deploying
to remote cluster cloud god knows that
and helps me find out a good image name
to deploy my a good registry to diploma
my images so GCI oh yes I do
and now kodkod will do the same thing
like bill my images tag my images send
the yellow files but this time it's
going to target my remote cluster and
when it's done it's going to give me a
endpoint that I can connect to we can
maybe switch to that cluster and CR is
going so we're gonna see that we have
deployments we can we can stream the
logs see it goes so it's basically
container creating so it's putting the
image it takes some time to to start the
container but in a few seconds it should
be started okay so let's leave it this
way and what we've seen is that it's
very easy to deploy your applications
continuously whether it's on a local
cluster or remote cluster with only the
cloud code deploy command cloud code
will help you all the way and when you I
have to type llamo or when you have to
debug Claude Claude is here to help so
told you it would be deployed let's try
it yeah I guess we work I'm on gke okay
so that's about it what I wanted to show
you on a cloud code let me switch back
to the slides
so how can you get it you can get it on
Visual Studio code on the marketplace
you can get it on IntelliJ with the
JetBrains plug-in repository or you can
go to club that google.com slash code
you can use the QR code and we're gonna
announce it officially tomorrow and if
you want to know more we have two other
sessions that you should attend so
there's the supercharge UGK development
workflow in vs code and IntelliJ and
there's daddy's equivalent workflows
with vs code and those two talks will
give you more details about cloud code
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]